WE WANT TO OPEN WITH LESS THAN
BREAKING NEWS.
THIS IS NOT A FOX NEWS ALERT.
I WAS GO, CONGRESSMAN SETH
MALDEN OF MASSACHUSETTS DROPPED
OUT OF THE RACE FOR THE
DEMOCRATIC NOMINATION.
IF YOU'VE NEVER HEARD OF
SETH MOULTON?
DORGAN MENOMINI HAVE.
HE SERVED IN THE UNITED STATES
RINKER NEW YORK FOUR TIMES BUT
OTHER THAN THAT HE HASN'T DONE
MUCH OTHER THAN THAT COLLECTING
USELESS CULTURE GAZE AND RUNNING
FOR OFFICE.
WHAT'S INTERESTING IS WHAT HE'S
BEING FORCED TO DROP OUT OF THE
RACE TODAY.
BY ANY SANE STANDARDS, WALTON IS
A THOROUGHLY LIBERAL DEMOCRAT.
ON EVERY ISSUE.
HE'S MORE LEFT-WING THEN
BARACK OBAMA WAS ON THE DAY HE
LEFT OFFICE.
THREE YEARS AGO, HE WOULD BE
CONSIDERED A LIBERAL FIREBRAND.
NOT ANYMORE.
BOY THE LUNATIC STANDARDS OF THE
MODERN DEMOCRATIC PARTY,
SETH MOULTON IS NOW A FLAMING
MODERATE AND THAT'S THE KISS OF
DEATH.
MODERATES ARE NOT WELCOME IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY ANY LONGER.
WATCH WHAT HAPPENS FOR EXAMPLE
AT THE LAST DEBATE WHEN
CONGRESSMAN KIM RYAN OF OHIO
URGED HIS FELLOW LIBERALS TO
TAKE A PRACTICAL CONSIDERATIONS
INTO ACCOUNT.
THEY TREATED HIM LIKE A MAN WITH
AN INFECTIOUS DISEASE.
WATCH THIS.
>> IN THIS DISCUSSION ALREADY
TONIGHT, WE TALKED ABOUT TAKING
PRIVATE HEALTH INSURANCE AWAY
FROM UNION MEMBERS IN THE
INDUSTRIAL MIDWEST.
WE TALKED ABOUT DECRIMINALIZING
THE BORDER AND WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT GIVING FREE HEALTH CARE TO
UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS WHEN SO
MANY AMERICANS ARE STRUGGLING TO
PAY FOR THEIR HEALTH CARE.
I QUITE FRANKLY DON'T THINK THAT
THAT IS AN AGENDA THAT WE CAN
MOVE FORWARD ON AND WHEN DID WE
GOT TO TALK ABOUT THE WORKING
CLASS ISSUES THAT.
THE PEOPLE TO TAKE A SHOWER
AFTERWARD WHO HAVEN'T HAD A
RAISE IN 30 YEARS.
IF WE FOCUS ON THAT, WE CAN WIN
THE ELECTION.
>> NOT A LOT OF APPLAUSE FOR
THAT.
THEN ONE FORM IS CONGRESSMAN
JOHN DELANEY TRIED TO ENCOURAGE
HIS PARTY TO RESTRICT ITS
AMBITIONS TO THE PHYSICALLY
POSSIBLE, ELIZABETH WARREN
ORDERED HIM TO BE BANISHED FROM
WONDERLAND FOREVER.
>> I THINK DEMOCRATS WIN WHEN WE
RUN ON REAL SOLUTIONS ON
IMPOSSIBLE PROMISES BUT WHEN WE
RUN ON THINGS THAT ARE WORKABLE,
NOT FAIRY TALE ECONOMICS.
BECAUSE YOU KNOW, I DON'T
UNDERSTAND WHY ANYBODY GO
THROUGH ALL THE TROUBLE OF
RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES JUST TO TALK ABOUT
WHAT WE REALLY CAN'T DO AND
SHOULDN'T FIGHT FOR.
I DON'T GET THAT.
>> Tucker: YOU AND YOUR
REALITY-BASED IDEAS.
HOW DARE YOU!
BEGUN.
DEMENTED, OBVIOUSLY, BUT AS A
POLITICAL MATTER, IT HAS BEEN
HIGHLY EFFECTIVE.
WHEN HE DROPPED OUT TODAY,
CONGRESSMAN MOULTON NOTED THAT
QUOTE, IT'S EVIDENT THIS IS NOW
A THREE-WAY RACE BETWEEN BIDEN
AND WARREN AND SANDERS AND
REALLY IT'S A DEBATE ABOUT HOW
FAR LEFT THE PARTY SHOULD GO.
EXCEPT, THERE ISN'T REALLY A
DEBATE.
THE FARTHEST LEFT CANDIDATES ARE
WINNING OF THE NEARLY 20 PEOPLE
IN THE FIELD, ONLY BIDEN,
WARREN, AND SANDERS CAN MUSTER
MORE THAN 10% OF SUPPORT.
WHICH IN FACT MAKES IT A
TWO-PERSON RACE IF WE ARE GOING
TO BE HONEST ABOUT IT AND WHY
WOULDN'T WE BE?
BIDEN MAY BE A DECENT PERSON BUT
HE'S FADING.
HE SAYS WITH THINGS A LOT AND HE
DID IT AGAIN TODAY IN
NEW HAMPSHIRE.
LISTEN TO THIS.
>> MY SENIOR SEMESTER THEY WERE
BOTH SHOT AND KILLED.
IMAGINE WHAT WHAT HAPPENED IF
GOD FORBID BARACK OBAMA HAD BEEN
ASSASSINATED AFTER BECOMING A
DEFECTIVE NOMINEE.
WHAT WOULD'VE HAPPENED IN
AMERICA?
>> Tucker: IMAGINE THAT YOU
ARE BIDEN'S CLINICAL DIRECTOR
SITTING OFFSTAGE AND ALL OF A
SUDDEN HE WANDERS INTO
UNSCRIPTED TERRITORY AND SAYS
IMAGINE THE ASSASSINATION OF
BARACK OBAMA.
YOU'VE GOT YOUR HEAD IN YOUR
HANDS AND FREQUENTLY AT TEXTING
REPORTERS TRY TO GET THEM TO
DEEMPHASIZE A PEERLESS BALANCE,
THIS IS NOT AN ATTACK ON
JOE BIDEN GET HE'S KNOCKING TO
BE THE NOMINEE.
HE'S NOT CAN BE THE PRESIDENT
DID I MEAN, SERIOUSLY.
HE IS NOT.
SO THE ACTUAL RACE COMES DOWN TO
WARREN AND SANDERS.
SANDERS.
COMPETING VISIONS OF HOW TO
ACHIEVE THE SAME SOCIALIST
FANTASY.
WARREN'S PROMISING REPARATIONS
BASED ON SKIN COLOR.
THAT'S POPULAR.
SANDERS WANTS A GOVERNMENT
TAKEOVER OF THE ENTIRE ENERGY
SECTOR.
OKAY.
THEY WILL BE WORKING TO OUT
CRAZY EACH OTHER FOR THE NEXT
SIX MONTHS.
THAT IS A DYNAMIC AND GUARANTEED
TO PRODUCE YET MORE EXTREMISM.
AND IT HAS SOME DEMOCRATIC
LEADERS WORRIED.
YESTERDAY FOR EXAMPLE, THE DNC
VOTED ON A PROPOSAL TO HOLD THE
DEBATE FOCUSED EXCLUSIVELY ON
CLIMATE CHANGE.
WHY WOULD THEY DO THAT?
WELL, BECAUSE THE SOLUTIONS THE
CANDIDATES WOULD PROMISE LIVE ON
TELEVISION ARE INSANE.
SPEND $16 TRILLION, THEN
AIRPLANES, SEIZE CONTROL OF THE
ENTIRE U.S. ECONOMY.
OKAY.
THE TRUST OF RIAN'S LOVE STUFF
LIKE THAT.
NORMAL PEOPLE FIND IT
TERRIFYING.
EVEN THE PARTY HACKS HERE IN
D.C. DON'T LIKE IT AND THAT'S
PROBABLY A COMPLEMENT HONESTLY.
YOU REALLY THINK NANCY PELOSI
BELIEVES CLIMATE CHANGE IS AN
EXISTENTIAL CRISIS?
OF COURSE SHE DOESN'T THINK
THAT.
PLUS, SHE FLIES PRIVATE PEER
BARACK OBAMA CAN SAY WHATEVER HE
WANTS ABOUT CARBON EMISSIONS,
SHOOK HIS CHIN COME AND BE VERY
CONCERNED BUT WHEN YOU ARE
SPENDING 15 MILLION OF YOUR OWN
DOLLARS ON A BEACHFRONT DATE IN
MARTHA'S VINEYARD, YOU ARE NOT
TOO WORRIED ABOUT THE OCEANS
RISING WHERE THE PROBLEM IS, THE
DEMOCRATIC BASE DOESN'T GET THE
JOKE.
DEMOCRATIC PRIMARY VOTERS
BELIEVE THE TALKING POINTS.